watchdogs to makes a life of cybercrime
in San Francisco almost irresistible fun
and what turned out to be a smart
maneuver Ubisoft dialed back the
self-serious cyberpunk drama from the
first game aiming for something closer
to an absurd hacker sitcom with grand
theft auto's irreverent atmosphere I
profile ops waiting for exposure and
laughs to get people to download our app
don't worry we spent almost 40 hours
with the game and though we were able to
beat every main objective and most side
missions not every aspect of watchdogs 2
was ready for Showtime leading up to
launch
in response to reports of heavy slow
down during multiplayer events Ubisoft
temporarily disabled seamless PvP last
week that we only experienced
multiplayer related framerate issues a
few times it was relentless when it
occurred rebooting the game was the only
cure we don't know if the issue will be
resolved before watchdogs 2 goes public
so our full review will have to wait
until we can test multiplayer in real
world conditions after launch however
everything outside of multiplayer seems
to be in working order with San
Francisco's skyline at your back you
guide our upbeat protagonist Marcus into
the open arms of dedsec a hack to this
group that fights for privacy and
justice against the likes of the FBI in
social network giants your partners come
on like strong cologne at times
overflowing with hacker cliches
goofiness and melodrama but their
likable nonetheless outside of dedsec
secret hideout the bay area's biggest
tech companies personalities and
headlines that steal the show
if you've ever wanted to harass the
nefarious Pharma bro Martin shkreli
or peer into the mind of a social
network bigwig there's a mission for
that holy [ __ ] I'm a huge fan are you
taking me up on my offer your smartphone
can manipulate electronics and vehicles
remotely thanks to its suite of dedsec
made apps and even leap between closed
circuit cameras to silently enter
municipal and corporate buildings
ladies and gentlemen pervert cold let's
wreck his world there is an art to
accomplishing your goals without being
noticed but if you prefer to stand tall
and carry a big stick
no major character questions your
tactics least of all Marcus himself you
are free to steal cars Rob the innocent
and infiltrate using brute force over
covert hacks provided you're good at
running from the police and watchdog
twos tongue-in-cheek world you're never
forced to confront the moral
consequences of your actions beyond
watching witnesses flee a crime scene
San Francisco and other Bay Area cities
and watchdogs to look and feel like
they're real counterparts but there is a
noticeable lack of traffic on sidewalks
and city streets this affords you fewer
opportunities to create chaos as a
result but the modestly populated roads
do make it easy to cruise around the bay
driving feels marginally better than the
last game with motorcycles offering the
most control and utility
there's a wonderful mix of urban variety
and natural beauty on the map and the
steep hills of San Francisco offer
plenty of opportunities for
death-defying stunts you can distract
yourself from the daunting task of
hacking the world by racing motocross
bikes go-karts and drones you can also
work on your selfie game and drive for a
ride-sharing service to earn extra cash
and attract new dedsec followers which
in turn allows you to unlock new hacking
abilities and purchase new weapons
though you are encouraged to shoot for a
specific playstyle you'll have no
problem if you diversify your skill sets
in fact the best moments in watchdogs 2
are when it presents open-ended
challenges that inspire you to mix and
match between hacking and armed combat
part of the reason watchdogs too can
allow you to be sneaky or explosive at a
moment's notice is that it's AI has a
few screws loose you aren't given the
chance to hide bodies which makes
stealth feel like a non option but this
is accounted for by easily distracted
NPCs with a simple command you can
distract or overwhelm enemies through
their smartphone even when they know
something sketchy is afoot then knock
them out before they can call for help
you can drive forklifts and scissor
lifts through crowds but no one seems to
bothered by the inconvenience with fast
and loose rules watchdogs too won't win
any points for realism but it does allow
you room to be the creative action hero
you apparently are there is a lot of joy
defined in playing watchdogs to solo but
multiplayer
when it works shouldn't be ignored there
are emergent PvP events that allow you
to hack or hunt down other players and
special missions were you and a partner
can infiltrate networks and private
property together we can imagine how a
full server of players has the potential
to make you feel connected to the world
and part of a larger community of
hackers we just can't test that theory
until the game is in the hands of more
people
watchdogs to is definitely an enjoyable
game but it remains to be seen if it can
seamlessly marry single and multiplayer
content without a hitch
Marcus we're on the news already